Whoa!
Das war's für heute.
Bis dahin, tschüss!
Das war's für heute, bis dahin, tschüss!
Das war's für heute.
Bis dahin, tschüss!
Einfaches, ja?
Was ich aber schon eine Weile ausprobieren wollte, nämlich, ob man gescheit Rust und
.NET zusammen verwenden kann.
Von der Idee her ist es easy, ja?
Einfach Rust Functions als C mit C-Interface exportieren und dann in C-Shop importieren,
aber ja, mal gucken.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Aber
Vielleicht sollte ich mal bevor der stream richtig anläuft und die leute da sind vielleicht soll ich mein update machen
Ja genau so macht man update so nicht anders
Ich habe meine klimaanlage an
Die läuft die steht auf 26 grad das reicht das ist dann meistens ein bisschen kühler als 26 grad zählt man aus ansonsten ist
Irgendwie 28,5 oder so viel zu warm also
Klimaanlage einbauen war tatsächlich eines der besten sachen
Die ich so überlegt habe denn die letzten jahre über ja
Warum ist der download so langsam?
Was ist denn da los
Warum ist das warum ist das so langsam ich habe eine split anlage ja sollte der nicht mehrere sachen gleichzeitig
downloaden eigentlich
Sekunde das muss ich mal kurz überprüfen sudo
Wartet mal etc pack man
Mein konf
parallel download nee
Ach gott wie ging das pack man parallel download das müssen wir uns mal kurz angucken
Was mit der seite los monka
Hier parallel download gleich fünf hatte ich das nicht schon mal gesetzt
Na gut, ich habe es jetzt schon mal gesetzt
Aber ich habe es jetzt schon mal gesetzt
Parallel download gleich fünf hatte ich das nicht schon mal gesetzt na gut im zweifelsfall setzen wir es noch mal
War hier noch nicht gesetzt ok
Dann
Ah jetzt flutscht jetzt flutscht
Ja ich muss mal kurz updaten bevor wir anfangen ist ist
Ich weiß schon eine weile ja nicht mehr an und wir haben auch schon eine weile nichts mehr gebastelt im stream und
Da muss ich erst mal updaten jetzt das geht aber schnell das ist ja kein windows update was jetzt erst mal
20 minuten rum macht es dauert drei vier minuten dann ist das ist das durch
Ja aber ich habe eine split klimaanlage ich habe ein außen gerät und zwei innen geräte und ich glaube ich könnte maximal
fünf innen geräte da dran anschließen ich habe eine
mit so bischi heavy
Wenn man mit so bisschen mutti buschi alles klar
Eine ja von denen habe ich was ja sieht mehr oder weniger sieht mehr oder weniger so aus wie das ding das kommt auch ungefähr hin
zrk
20 zsw ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es das die ist aber das klingt relativ ähnlich zu der die ich die ich
gekauft habe ja
Ja so ein teil
So ein teil habe ich an der wand
Sowas hängt außen und sowas hängt bei mir im arbeitszimmer und im schlafzimmer
Drinnen kann ich mich nicht beschweren ist wirklich in ordnung
Besser besser auf jeden fall als diese kompromiss dinger mit schlauch durchs fenster und so das
Aber klimaanlage kann ich nur empfehlen die zweite sache die ich empfehlen kann ist ein klo mit popo spülung
Aber und natürlich ein gut guter büro stuhl ordentlicher büro stuhl
Für 24 sieben sitzen ausgelegt
Klo dass den bob es abspritzen kann und eine klimaanlage das sind so die wichtigsten sachen die man für daheim braucht
Mit so bischi ist ein riesen ding die das sind ja auch teilweise das sind ja unter komplett unterschiedliche unternehmen mittlerweile
Die die haben ja sogar zwei verschiedene klimaanlagen sparten die haben mit so bischi elektrik und mit so bischi heavy industries
Die machen beides klimaanlagen
Und nein meine sinkpad battery functions funktionieren nicht das ist ja ganz schlimm in meiner vm
Na ja wenn sie aus ist kostet es kein geld
Aber du wirst sie mehr als 20 tage im jahr brauchen
Du wirst die bestimmt zwischendurch auch mal für also man kann ja für mehrere sachen verwenden du kannst die wenn du allergisch bist gegen
irgendwelche polen gräser und sonst was kannst du damit
das
Filtern lassen oder was es das filtert ja nicht dass das das elektroschock die dinger ja immer und
Und dann sind dann geht das geht das zeug kaputt irgendwie weiß nicht wie das genau funktionieren
Also wenn man wenn man allergien hat gegen irgendwelche polen und gräser dann ist das ganz sinnvoll
Du kannst damit wärmen im winter sollte mal deine heizung probleme haben und du kannst damit kühlen und es gibt ja mittlerweile schon
auch
Sagen wir mal
gut januar februar
märz april
Mai mai mai juni gibt es ja manchmal so spitzen tage teilweise 35 grad oder so wo es dann mal ganz gut funktioniert
35 grad oder so wo es dann mal ganz kurz so spiked hoch geht also wirst wahrscheinlich öfters verwenden
Also ich kann das nur empfehlen klimaanlage ist porc sollte sich muss man paar y-zweck machen
Also ich ich kann es nur empfehlen
Ich 50 fenster auf habe ich hab nicht 50 fenster offen ich habe mindestens 300 fenster offen hier
So jetzt müssen wir mal rebooten bevor wir richtig loslegen können
mal körner
Mal körner update machen noch mal bei der gelegenheit
Und hier was haben wir denn hier 515 das ist ja uralt aber lts
ja
Scheiß drauf ich meine es ist nicht. So als wäre es für meine vor allem großartig den unterschied
Und warum weil da halt sachen drin auf sind die ich auf haben will
Wo ich vielleicht noch mal reingucken will und ich noch nicht zugemacht habe ich meine was ist denn schon mal
Weil ich sie halt aufgemacht habe
Also bei mir war das total einfach dass die klimaanlage kamen außen an die wand dann wurde ein loch gebohrt
Durch die wand dahinter ist das arbeitszimmer und vom arbeitszimmer durch die andere wand ins schlafzimmer
Ja, wenn du jetzt natürlich dann von der einen außen wand einmal quer durch stockwerk willst ins andere zimmer
Man muss dann überlegen wo du das rohr lang machst das ist dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter ich bin auch
gerade am überlegen ob ich nicht noch drei weitere anlagen anschließt weil ich kann ja bis zu fünf
Also ich kann ja bis zu fünf in in geräte da dran anschließen an meiner klimaanlage
Und ich bin gerade am überlegen ob ich
Und ich bin gerade am überlegen ob ich nicht noch ins wohnzimmer oben eine packen soll so ein innengerät
unten ins schlafzimmer und
In in in flur wobei flur weiß ich nicht
Ja mal gucken
Wenn ich bin ich am überlegen ob ich nicht noch
Ja mal gucken wenn ich bin ich am überlegen
Ja es gibt jede menge
Addons ja wo du das dann auch kopiert speichern kannst und so braucht man aber alles nicht ich zeig das mal
Guck mal leute ihr könnt das markieren hier oben alle tabs auf einmal markieren
und
Ne das nicht und dann könnt ihr sagen
Anlagen
Ich hab vergessen wie es geht man konnte alle bookmarken lassen
Bookmark all tabs kannst du mal
Und dann kannst du den ordner auswählen wo das rein soll und dann kannst du die da drin speichern aber ganz ehrlich
Klimaanlagen sind für mein klima im haus ziemlich gut
Hat ja keinen sinn warum soll ich schwitzen
Zahlt saumäßig warm
So jetzt hat das ding rebooted
Also es ist schon ein unterschied ob es 28 grad drinne ist oder 26 das macht schon was aus man muss es ja nicht übertreiben
Man muss das jetzt ja nicht irgendwie auf 23 grad runter kühlen oder sowas
Hast du solaranlage auf dem dach ne hätte ich aber gerne habe ich noch nicht ich habe mich dieses jahr
Also ich hatte mich dieses jahr mal ein bisschen schlau gemacht welche richtung und so am besten ist
aber
Ich habe ich hätte ich hätte gern was ich bin mir aber noch nicht ganz sicher wie das am besten funktioniert
muss ja auf jeden fall was mit batterie sein und dann ist es wieder die frage mit
wie geht das dass man
das irgendwie
Anschließen kann an stromnetz und dann muss ja irgendwelche muss ja irgendwie mehrere
zähler haben und und bis zu 600 watt gehen irgendwie ohne aber
Ach, das ist das in deutschland wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ich habe so nicht so ganz gecheckt
Na ja
Also das dach ist gedämmt das ist glaube ich das einzige was halbwegs gedämmt ist aber das ist halt kein
Kein keconer haus das ist ein haus das hatten wirklich richtig dicke
Wie nennt sie das so diese dicken steine wo man oder opa früher wo opa und oma früher noch das haus mit gebaut haben
Also das ist nicht wirklich isoliert
Aber das ist kein papp haus
Wenigen stromverbrauch ja gut
Das stimmt schon aber es hat ja auch keinen sinn zu schwitzen irgendwo
Ja also preise preise sind saumäßig hoch
Ich glaube ich habe damals 2000 euro oder so bezahlt 2500 euro oder irgendwie sowas für dieses gesamte ding und heute bezahlt
Du das irgendwie für so ein innen gerät oder so es ist teilweise schon echt übertrieben teuer
So also jetzt haben wir den kram
So
Nee ich weiß es also wenn ich könnte euch genau sagen da müsste ich nachgucken
Ich weiß es nicht mehr müsste ich auf die rechnung gucken die habe ich irgendwo noch was das gekostet hat alles in allem
Der einbau war aber relativ schnell erledigt die haben das an einem halben vormittag gemacht also
An einem halben tag die haben vormittags haben sie es eingebaut
Die haben es morgens angerückt und irgendwie keine ahnung kurz vor zwölf waren die fertig war easy
Also ich kann das nur empfehlen sich eine klimaanlage einzubauen ja das stimmt schon irgendwo dass das letztendlich für die gesamt wie soll man so die
Gesamt energie verbrauchen so sicherlich nicht gut ist aber ganz ehrlich
Irgendwann ist mit der selbst geißelung auch gut
Ich meine man muss es nicht übertreiben wie die amis die ja teilweise gar keine fenster mehr aufmachen sondern nur klimaanlage
Die ihre kranplätze welche kranplätze
Das kann grad das einzige was sie gebraucht haben die hatten so was die hatten die hatten so was zum zum hochklettern
An an an der seite das ist das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich hoch wo das hängt
Ja die dinger mit schlauch sind kacke
Deswegen habe ich ja auch vor zwei drei nehmt eigentlich wahrscheinlich sogar schon vier jahre her oder so ich weiß es gar nicht mehr
habe ich mir das einbauen lassen
Ja typisch typisch sparen das ist ja nichts neues
Kackel
So das war's für heute
Das ist ja nichts neues ja kackel so noch mal hier updates machen und können wir anfangen
Wie lange wir da verbrauchen heute weiß ich nicht genau wenn es klappt dann klappt wenn es nicht klappt wird es eklig
erst noch mal hier updates machen
Richtig richtig so sieht es aus
Ja morgen gehe ich wieder arbeiten allerdings ich fahre die woche nicht nach frankfurt
Das bin ich noch nicht fit genug ich mache die woche nach homeoffice und dann die woche drauf wieder
Mal ein zwei tage nach frankfurt
Mal gucken was was da so ansteht ich war jetzt zwei wochen nicht da ich habe bestimmt wieder einiges verpasst
Wo sich wieder irgendwelche neuen schwachsinnigen sachen ausgedacht wurden
Aber wollen wir mal schauen
Wollen wir mal schauen so ja massive password kommt keiner drauf
Ne emails emails habe ich ja nebenbei schon ein bisschen geguckt emails habe ich ja immer hier auf dem handy so
Scroll ich ja immer just for fun ab und zu mal durch
Und es ist nichts nichts wichtiges dabei das einzige das irgendjemand geschrieben hat ich soll mal mein profil
in unserem wiki aktualisieren
Ja gut
Ich bin juckt das profil in unserem wiki da guckt eh niemand rein
Aber mache ich dann irgendwann mal
Du das mittwoch nach frankfurt gg jetzt
Hätte ich keinen bock drauf wobei ich glaube am mittwoch wird es kühler oder zeigt man hier kurz wetter
Frankfurt
Am mittwoch wird es ein bisschen kühler ja
Am mittwoch ist anscheinend noch relativ warmer und donnerstag freitag samstag sonntag wird es relativ relativ cool
cool wird es da
Ich muss jetzt übrigens kachelmann wetter verwenden mich hat nachdem ich nachdem ich ja der kachelmann persönlich mal angekackt hat auf twitter
warum ich so kacke wetter seiten verwende
Kein spaß jetzt muss ich jetzt halt kachelmann wetter verwenden keine chance so
14 die seite ist aber für die übelst unübersichtlich
Das liegt ja auch hier an meinem dark reader so zeige ich mal ja also wie wird das so
mittwoch donnerstag
Sonst 22 27 und 20 ja ok das ist aber gut dass es einfach mal ein bisschen kühl wird ich mein kühl
26 25 grad ist nicht was man sagen könnte hier winter bricht ein aber wenigstens ein bisschen kühler
Ich glaube es freuen sich alle wenn es mal ein paar tage regnet und es ein bisschen bisschen kühler ist so
Ich glaube update orgie ist fertig
Ja die seite ist furchtbar responsive update leute
Wie lang wie lang habe ich schon nichts mehr gemacht hier guck mal ist alles geupdatet werden
Die musik zu laut passt
Auf gib alles jetbrain toolbox
So das ist das test
auf gib alles jetbrain des toolbox alter was macht es denn da moin eax
das aber äußerst guckt euch mal die systemauslastung an der ist aber
ziemlich ziemlich hardcore am updaten gerade taint so moin
auf gib ihm jetzt mach mal endlich installen in der zwischenzeit hast du ja eine neue winnows vm
installiert das heißt schon was ok gleich haben wir es geschafft wie es aussieht betop ja wir
können zugucken was er so macht guckt euch das hier mann massive auslastung
betop ist für alle den hardtop nicht fancy genug ist
ascii aquarium ja das ist selbstverständlich auch installiert übrigens guckt mal hier unten das
ascii aquarium ist im gnome terminal kaputt wenn man das wenn man das im x wenn man das mal in
dem x-term auf macht ich glaube ich habe x-term x-term gar nicht mehr installiert weil man warum
auch ja aber wenn man das mal in dem x-term auf macht das ascii aquarium dann werdet ihr feststellen
das hat mehr details der schwarn sieht auch nach schwarn aus und hier unten ist eine burg und so warum
peitsch haben nur community edition gute frage hat keinen tieferen sinn kommt man das hat nämlich
auch wasserblasen und so und das hat es hier überhaupt nicht seht ihr ist viel viel detail
armor im gnome terminal so ist so ist viel viel besser hier im x-term fisch k.i. kannst du ein
video machen wo du alle plugins und third party ich habe da gar nicht so viel drauf das ist
eigentlich relativ minimalistisch das ist in i3 mit gnome terminal browser und paar idees
drauf ansonsten ist da nicht viel liegt an der font size ne liegt nicht an der font size guck
liegt nicht an der font size der hat probleme hier mit den escape sequenzen von von der farbe
anscheinend keine ahnung mal gucken wie ist dieses terminal was ich mir mal letztens installiert
hab oder chat meinte das ist ganz furchtbar geil nee wie ist denn das nee war das aller
haben wir schon wieder runter geschmissen aller aller kredi alter alter kredi so gucken ob das
ob das da besser funktioniert aski aquarium ne guck ist auch procken nur nur original im x-term
jetzt mein mental mental brain fog geht der fog immer noch so vor sich hin aber wir probieren
das heute mal aus ob ich ein bisschen konzentrieren kann also so gehen wir mal unser repo wir brauchen
unser repo verzeichnis legen wir für heute was an bekommt man den tuja converter einfach auf
einer windows maschine nee nee nee nee das ist für das ist exklusiv für respiratory pi gedacht
das ding nee brauchst du es bei ich weiß nicht ob die mittlerweile andere single board computer
unterstützen aber du brauchst du es bei guck hier steht doch ach nee gucke mal du kannst
auch kali linux 2018.4 mvm wer verwendet alles klar ok war mir so nicht klar aber also ganz
ehrlich am einfachsten funktioniert es mit raspberry pi da musst du auch einfach nichts
machen außer git repo klonen und und runterladen so mk dir wie nennen wir das projekt cute rust
so also dort net new moment welche welche dort net version haben wir hier eigentlich
am start version preview 6 das ist outdated overrated tschibated nein so nenne ich es
bestimmt nicht wir müssen install dort net install sieben ja wir brauchen das neueste preview
sonst geht ja hier nix finish successful so version preview sieben alles klar prog so new
console nee im moment minus o war das minus o für output directory ich weiß weiß kann ich
console top minus o ja minus o so und jetzt cargo new so wie nennen wir wie nennen wir das rust
projekt cute lip es die cute cute lip cute search slip ich wollte ja ein bisschen was mit
suchen mit mit search engines ausprobieren so wunderbar jetzt haben wir unsere projekte
da bin ich ja bin ich ja begeistert ok dann machen wir mal weiter auf für den dort net
teil und machen mal mit was habe ich rast das letzte mal gemacht ich glaube mit mit
sea lion und dem rust plugin glaube ruby mein nee ruby mein brauche ich eher nicht
7.0 ist not fully supported ja da kann ich mit leben das ist in ordnung
gut weg damit so see lion aufmachen also bevor ich wieder mit emacs anfangen dann weiß
auch nicht ich habe früher mal relativ relativ religiös emacs verwendet was ist denn hier
los rust version is not compatible monka es was ist denn hier los ei sekunde check for
updates nee about nee plugins wie macht man hier updates gescheit da ober war das doch
ge update plugins ja gib ihm update aber ganz ehrlich emacs finde ich hat relativ wenig
daseinsberechtigung noch seit visual studio code das coole an emacs war die erweiterbarkeit
aber das ist ja wirklich um welten übertroffen mit visual studio code der einzige vorteil
den emacs hat es vielleicht wenn man so auf so jahrelang auf so sachen geschwört hat
wie org mode oder ich weiß nicht ob jemand von euch schon mal org mode verwendet hat und
da irgendwie sehr viel sehr viel zeug in seiner knowledge base drin stehen hat und das weiter
verwenden will ok aber ansonsten ehrlich gesagt sehe ich heutzutage wenig einsatzzwecke für
emacs noch bei wim sieht das anders aus wim ist nach wie vor ein super terminal editor
gerade für server wenn man psh drauf ist aber emacs sehe ich jetzt nicht so wirklich die
daseinsberechtigung noch so machen wir das noch mal neu auf jetzt öffnen wir mal das
verzeichnis mit dem rast projekt drinne nicht das sondern das das neue repos yeah huge search
lip ok yes wir trusten alles des window gib ihm was macht er denn für dinge im hintergrund
ach vielleicht soll ich mal rast aktualisieren wie geht das rast update ok erstmal das halbe
internet runterladen und neu kompilieren für die neue rast version gg eats macht er denn
da soll er mal machen soll mir recht sein mach mach einfach mal rast ist ist ok gut
naja ist doch relativ übersichtlich gewesen also was ich jetzt mal ausprobieren will ist
folgendes ich will was in rast ja ich ich will was in rast programmieren und will das
von totnet aufrufen ich habe da einen ich habe da ein artikel zugelesen irgendwie sowas
hier aber das war an sich relativ relativ easy man muss man muss wo steht es denn alles
schwachsinn das braucht man alles nicht doch alles blödsinn was machen die denn da das
braucht man überhaupt nicht ah moment das ist c sharp from rast moment das ist falsch
rum das will ich doch gar nicht schon mal barbie als editor genutzt nee was ist denn
barbie editor github a text editor ein python based editor warum und warum sollte ich das
verwenden ich meine nano ist ja nur wirklich der größte schwachsinn überhaupt und dann
noch der nano variante in python die nirgendswo vorinstalliert ist den den sinn verstehe ich
nicht so ganz how we integrate rast with the sharp ja genau das das hatte ich gelesen so
und das war sich das war sich fast genau also so wie ich das verstanden hat muss man folgendes
machen was ist das hier schon wieder für alter nee das ist nicht das was ich gesehen habe
es ist komplett komplett pepega was die hier schreiben das braucht man alles gar nicht
wtf calling rast from c sharp ja ja das sieht besser aus wie das also im prinzip ist es
total einfach man sagt dass der projekt type in rast das ist eine nee das stimmt nicht
das muss c c dynamic library heißen und dann das hier ist das einzige was man machen muss
also man muss man muss schreiben extern function und dann no mangel drüberschreiben was
dazu dafür sorgt dass der name erhalten bleibt im binary so dass man dann in c sharp mit
diesem funktionsnamen die ganze sache importieren kann ja also von der idee her ist das relativ
easy das probieren wir probieren wir einfach mal so aus nehmen einfach mal das beispiel
von denen hier komm ich lasse es einfach eins zu eins so wie es ist so ja und warum ich das
warum ich mir das ganze angeguckt habe ist ich habe was ich habe ein cooles projekt gefunden
in rust irgendwie so das ist eine search engine also eine volltext suche in rust es gibt für
so gut wie alle programmier sprachen irgendwelche projekte die sowas machen aber das sah wirklich
cool aus ich war man könnte auch gleich die volltext suche aus sq lite verwenden oder
lucille.net oder so wobei ich davon keine ahnung habe aber ich dachte mir ich wollte
mir also warum ich ich zeige euch das mal ich wollte mir in nächster zeit mal avalonier
angucken avalonier ist ein cross platform gui framework für dotnet und ich dachte wir machen
einfach so ein ganz billiges ich kann die dateien durchsuchen auf meinem rechner gui
also wirklich in gui mit einer suchleiste drinnen und in der listbox fertig so und dazu
muss ich jetzt halt mal irgendwie die dateien auf dem rechner indizieren also die dateifade
und vielleicht wenn es die text datei ist auch den inhalt und das könnte man so könnte
man nämlich zwei fliegen mit einer klatsche erschlagen man könnte einmal könnte ich
ein bisschen c sharp rust interop ausprobieren und ich könnte mir avalonier angucken das
würde besser funktionieren als die windows search bar ja gut das ist ja auch keine kunst
die windows search bar die funktioniert ja auch einfach gar nicht ja so ungefähr dachte
ich mir das auch ja moment dl import da gibt es jetzt was neues es gibt jetzt library import
das ist jetzt seit dotnet 7 ist das neu das können wir auch gleich ausprobieren es gibt
jetzt es gibt jetzt library import warum man das verwenden soll habe ich noch nicht so
genau gecheckt aber das das probieren wir jetzt probieren es gleich mal aus also so
als war mir erstmal den rust teil great teil ne ne das habe ich mir aufgeschrieben was
da drin stehen muss weil ich wusste dass ich das nicht mehr finde das muss das muss da
rein das ist totaler blödsinn was da steht hier ich copy paste das jetzt ich habe mir
das im fortfall schon rausgesucht weil ich wusste dass ich den richtigen artikel wo
ich wo ich das gefunden habe wahrscheinlich nicht mehr finde so das muss da drinne stehen
so und jetzt können wir den ganzen kram mal kompilieren und gucken ob das funktioniert
ach so stimmt du hast recht es muss lip heißen ja ja ihr habt recht chat wieder absolut
pfeil fährt lip muss es heißen warum nicht selber nägel samaran ist ja dead es ist jetzt
maui und maui ist ja gut aber maui ist samaran und samaran hat gesagt und maui sagt weiterhin
also das ist die technologie ich bin ja großer dort nett und sie scharf fern aber das ist
die technologie die lasse ich an mir vorbeiziehen also als absoluter pains champ ne jetzt heißt
jetzt heißt maui dort nett das ist so der neueste scheiß jetzt von microsoft was in
anführungsstrichen cross platform ui ist aber es war schon du hast recht es war schon immer
scheiße samaran war scheiße und maui ist auch scheiße ne da will ich nichts machen ganz
ehrlich ne ne ob maui stable ist oder nicht wäre mir fast egal solange es funktioniert
für das was ich machen will aber ne ne das das gebe ich mir nicht leute das das gebe
ich mir nicht kein bock ok wo müssen wir den repos cute rust rust lip cargo bild wie
das wars jetzt wait a minute lip cute search lip punkt so warte mal das ist falsch benannt
leute oder die coolen rust leute das das darf doch nicht so heißen oder was ist denn rust
rust five head time genau das muss anders heißen das muss das muss cute search lip es
wahrscheinlich sogar noch heißen oder die rust leute haben doch immer gerne es hinten
dran und jetzt und jetzt ganz wichtig description blazing fast written in rust was braucht man
noch blazing fast written in rust fire emoji fire emoji ja ja so ganz wichtig ganz wichtig
ach ja und die krabbe das krabben emoji muss auch noch ein leute benennt man rust packages
mit rs hinten dran oder nicht das sind ja nicht rastana das sind ja rust crust oder
rast rastaschens oder so nennen die sich ja die rust leute ist teilweise schon ein bisschen
also in go und in rust die leute schreiben prinzipiell ihre libraries und und und projekte
immer dabei dass sie in rust oder in go written sind ok bild ist das jetzt in ordnung darf
man das jetzt so machen dead code oh nein moment moment leute ich muss mir mal kurz
ich muss mir mal kurz das leben einfacher machen das wird wahrscheinlich auch den den
wahren rust feinschmecker jetzt abschrecken aber ich habe keinen bock auf kompiler generve
ja gleich schon viel besser viel besser keck so bild kann man so was machen wie minus
o teckel punkt so geht das nee
kann man irgendwie den output namen bei cargo bild angeben cargo bild output name ja ich
weiß dass ich im target folder gucken kann aber ich will nicht und dann geht das net
ja gut da muss ich copy pasten weil eigentlich also was ich jetzt machen wollte ist sowas
hier ich wollte eigentlich dass hier reinkopieren in den ordner oben drüber in das in das dotnet
weil da muss es ja letztendlich hin ja ich muss ich wusste wahrscheinlich muven genau
also cargo bild und jetzt haben wir im target ordner im moment cargo bild minus c release
ging das so nee ach mist cargo bild release minus minus release ok ich mach zu viel unterschiedliche
dinge da blicke ich den mal durch minus minus release oder einfach nur minus r so jetzt
haben wir den kram hier drin also ich muss das ich muss das bilden und dann muss ich
danach den ganzen krempel anscheinend noch mal kopieren target release hier lip lip cute
search lip das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel das guten der name oder das heißt
einfach nur cute search und den rest macht da hinten dran also cp target release hier
lip cute search und das ganze soll jetzt in die console app wunderbar so und jetzt probieren
wir das ganze mal aus zu aufzurufen aus dem net program wichtig ist man muss in dem projekt
in dem dotnet projekt hinstellen dass er bei bild action nee nicht mal bild action die
datei in output ordner kopieren soll weil sonst findet er die beim ausführen nicht
ja du kannst du kannst auf nachrichten antworten das geht aber auch erst seit ich würde sagen
so in einem dreiviertel jahr oder sowas das ist noch nicht so lang drinne also das das
ist ein pleading edge twitch feature hallo warum geht mein console right line makro nicht
was ist hier los console right line kacke kacke ok und jetzt kommt man schön nicht gleich
wieder die frage warum verwendest du nicht das terminal in der ide weil ich das ide terminal
nicht mag und das rumleggt so dort net run funktioniert alles klar so und jetzt versuchen
wir mal die rust funktion aufzurufen aus c sharp raus also das ding heißt adnumbers
kriegt einen in 32 als input und kriegt zwei in 32 als input und kriegt in 32 als output
es heißt von der ide her das ist nicht intelli j das ist sie leyen und das ist rider aber
ja das ist beides von jet brains und dementsprechend sieht das sehr intelli j ähnlich aus so also
hier machen wir eine neue klasse interop so unsave code müssen wir auf jeden fall anmachen
weil sonst wird das garantiert nicht funktionieren unsave code unsave code so und jetzt muss
ich mal gucken wir machen es erstmal auf den alten weg dll import dll name ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob ich das punkt so hinten angeben muss oder nicht gibs ich gibs mal so an es
kann auch sein dass man extern z machen muss so und jetzt dll import jetzt muss ich mal
kurz überlegen muss man jetzt sagen extern ich glaube man muss jetzt sagen das macht
man nicht so auf public static extern und dann quasi int als rückgabe wert dann den
name adnumbers man kann glaube ich auch die c sharp schreibweise nehmen numbers und dann
muss man hier oben aber sagen entry point adnumbers so als parameter in 32 und in 32 b so und wenn
jetzt alles funktioniert und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert sollte der wenn ich das aufrufe
diese funktion in rust benutzen und er sollte einmal auf die konsole hello from rust schreiben
und als return wert nummer a plus nummer b zurück liefern chat meinte es funktioniert
also ich denke schon es sei denn ich hab mich verschrieben weil soviel soviel können wir
nicht falsch machen glaube noch ist es nicht so kompliziert also probieren wir das mal
aus interop adnumbers sagen wir mal warum geht man console weiter an marco nicht also
1 plus 2 also es sollte jetzt es sollte jetzt auf der kommando zeile rauskommen 3 und hello
from rust wenn das funktioniert easy funktioniert dazu kann man nur sagen easy easy aber das
war doch die einfache variante easy also das noch die einfache variante ich mein ins zu
übergeben ist relativ relativ easy so wir müssen jetzt als nächstes gucken wie über
gibt man strings und muss man sich irgendwie ums aufräumen kümmern oder so vielleicht
und ein struct übergeben das ist auch das ist auch eine gute gute ja ja müssen wir
gucken wie das funktioniert also vorher probieren wir jetzt noch mal was anderes und zwar gibt
es jetzt was neues es gibt nämlich in der library import und angeblich angeblich ist
library import jetzt die bessere alternative zu dl import warum habe ich ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht so genau verstanden aber wenn microsoft das sagt dann dann ist das wahrscheinlich
so oder probieren wir mal ob das überhaupt in der preview variante funktioniert gibt
brauche auf jeden fall soll mal gucken ob es noch funktioniert kaputt ok moment es muss
anders public static partial nicht nicht string int ok das funktioniert schon mal nett weil
public static class ok das schon mal interessant dass nicht mal das beispiel von microsoft
selbst funktioniert ok gut dass microsoft beispiel selbst funktioniert schon mal nicht
muss ich muss ich public static partial class machen oder so ok das funktioniert dann ist
das microsoft block eintracht nur pepega also wie viel wie viel keywords gehen denn
hier noch geht es jetzt easy funktioniert also soweit ich das verstanden habe ist der
unterschied folgender dl import geht ja so geht ja das heißt dl import weil es noch
aus windows zeiten es hat mit dl aber eigentlich nix mehr wirklich zu tun das geht ja schon
ewig seit c sharp eins quasi und sie haben es jetzt irgendwie umgebaut dass das source
code generator verwendet anstatt irgendwelche irgendwelchen dynamisch erzeugten el code
und das ist laut microsoft viel besser ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ob das besser
ist oder warum das besser ist aber wenn microsoft meint dass es so gut ist dann dann machen
wir das einfach mal ja also partial ist es weil das source code generator unter der haube
hat also es wird wahrscheinlich im output irgendwelche zusatzdinger generate wir können ja mal
kurz gucken schaap lab weiß ich ob die das ob die das schon können hau mal jetzt broken
meint es ist falsche ich glaube ich habe es kaputt gemacht ach nee ich muss umschalten
auf dotnet auf dotnet sieben oder wie kann ich hier auf dotnet sieben umschalten ich
danke für den sub ja die schaap next oder was muss ich hier auswählen ich habe keinen
plan ob das vielleicht kann das schaap lab nicht weil der rest ist alles der rest ist
alles uralt wenn ich das auswähle geht das dann also keine ahnung ich kann euch jetzt
nicht zeigen was der unter der haube macht aber anscheinend ist das der neue way wie
man das mit dotnet ab dotnet sieben machen soll so jetzt wird es natürlich kompliziert
wie übergibt man strings man kann ja anscheinend schon mal angeben wie das ganze übersetzt
werden soll weil rust hat ja utf 8 strings und sie schaap hat utf 16 strings das heißt
einfach irgendwie memory kopieren ist schon mal nett also will ich utf 8 haben so und
jetzt probieren wir das ganze mal wobei wir lassen das erstmal so hier das brauchen wir
an der stelle gar nicht so wir machen jetzt noch mal eine neue funktion in rust und probieren
mal ein paar strings zu übergeben ob das irgendwie passt ja nennen wir einfach mal
irgendwie was weiß ich konkert string oder so sehr egal so also s1 s2 und jetzt ist rust
logik was muss ich jetzt hier übergeben nen string nee oder nen c c char array oder
sowas ja da hört jetzt bei mir auf string die von stars oh ja sind auch beispiele beispiele
für für structs und sowas what about strings
ja vielleicht vielleicht memory leaken wir jetzt auch irgendwas
muss ich wirklich den kram freeen danach ernsthaft
ja gut eigentlich eigentlich ist es logisch dass ich das freeen muss danach
oh nee hör mal auf ich okay erstmal gucken wie man den string überhaupt rein bekommt
okay das ach du scheiße input vermutlich einfach als und zeste meinste aha oje oje
ich ahne schlimmes leute ich ahne schlimmes ich ahne schlimmes das wird was okay wir haben
schon mal kein int als rückgabe wert wir geben einfach aus okay ich will einfach nur
gucken ob das aufrufen funktioniert brennt aber wie ging das den rast noch mal so oder
oder war das go leute ich bin verwirrt war das go oder war das wie gebe ich wie gebe
ich rast aus s1 nee okay das funktioniert cannot be formatted ach ja doppelpunkt slash
es ist not ffe safe das dachte ich mir dass es not ffe safe ist mal gucken was passieren
wenn ich das passiert wenn ich das jetzt aufrufe wahrscheinlich erstmal direkt crash es wird
wahrscheinlich direkt direkt erstmal gecrashed so string marshaling gleich utf 8 ja sowas
such ich sowas sowas in der richtung brauche wahrscheinlich so es sollte übrigens strings
heißen aber egal so wir haben das wird doch im leben nix das wird doch im leben nix okay
der kram kompiliert noch alles klar okay also interop konkert string heckl aber das da
oben mal weg ach so zwei heckl oh was monka der hat das nicht richtig escaped oder
ich würde mal sagen ziemlich ziemlich overflow bisschen oder oder ist das die debug und ich
muss ich muss da ich muss aus diesem streng okay ich habe ich habe was ist okay ich achtung
mal meine rast meine rast logik also meine rast logik ein c string und ein c also der
unterschied mit s2 mache ich noch gar nix also der unterschied ist wahrscheinlich folgender
so laut der rast logik die ich so so mitbekommen das hier ist einfach nur ein wie heißt das
in rast einfach nur ein ein borrowed also ein pointer auf einen string im ram und das
hier ist quasi ein ownership string oder so wo sich dann mein rast auch ums aufräumen
kümmert würde ich jetzt mal so raten ist das jetzt eigentlich utf ich habe keine ahnung
mal frage mich sagen ja mal gucken was passiert wenn ich s2 ausgibt dann kreis dann kreis
okay alles klar oder klimaanlage wieder mal anmachen also bei bei s1 kommt was raus bei
s2 kommt nix raus schon mal schon mal interessant zu wissen so wir machen das jetzt richtig
der chat hat irgendwas sinnvolles gepostet vorhin
t-buff konst was sowas ich muss das wahrscheinlich erst mal ordentlich pasen in den rast string
also wahrscheinlich muss ich jetzt irgendwie sowas machen wie string prom oder sowas
vom c string oder oder c string from from ra so let let keck okay was stört den daran
jetzt uns safe okay kann man kann man direkt sagen alles uns safe jawohl expected mutt
c war what s pointer jawohl ne monka es ich glaube ich kann das gar nicht so übergeben
oder macht das okay und stag overflow stag overflow hat ahnung stag overflow weiß bescheid
aha c string from pointer aber das kann das kann doch nicht wirklich sein aber das ist
doch kein gültiger typ das ist doch kein gültiger doch was die rast die die rast syntax
irritiert mich immer wieder das doch eindeutig c syntax so oder nicht na gut okay und jetzt
und jetzt was c string from buffer c string from buffer s1 let okay darf ich das jetzt
printen bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert zeigt mal her das funktioniert ich bin mir
zwar nicht so ganz sicher was ich da gemacht habe jetzt aber es funktioniert was ist jetzt
der unterschied zwischen c strill und c string das hier ist nur das hier ist quasi nur eine
read only kopie und das hier ist quasi ich kann damit alles machen was ich will oder wie
das ist rast ja es sieht zwar nicht aus wie rast aber es ist rast s1 let keck okay das
funktioniert so nicht weil ss mutt nee pointer konst karst ich hab keine ahnung was du von
mir willst aber moment was das ist wieder was anderes okay keine ahnung aber aber ist
ja auch egal es ist auch vollkommen in ordnung so ist okay das funktioniert ja das dachte
ich mir genau genau das das dachte ich mir auch das dachte ich mir so also das würde
aber auch heißen dass ich jetzt memory leake oder wir benennen das übrigens mal richtig
ja das würde ja also im prinzip auch heißen dass ich memory leake oder nicht weil es ist
ja nur eine referenz es ist ja nur eine referenz auf den speicher also ich sollte kein memory
leaken eigentlich theoretisch sollte ich kein memory leaken
solange solange dotnet danach den kram aufräumt also ich weiß halt nicht was was das macht
es nimmt auf jeden fall sein managed string und macht da irgendeinen c bytearray string
draus und da weiß ich halt nicht räumt das danach auf oder nicht call die funktion und
ja das machen wir probieren wir probieren das aus wir probieren das aus probieren wir
probieren mal aus die ausgabe machen wir mal weg und wir übergeben wir übergeben mal
ein bisschen längeren erst einmal übersetzen okay scheinbar funktionieren also wenn ich
was retorne dann muss ich mich auf jeden fall um das aufräumen in dotnet selbst kümmern
von dem unmanaged part aber das mache ich ja nicht ich retorne ja kein string okay
probieren wir das mal aus ich würde jetzt ehrlich gesagt das ganz einfach machen mache
jetzt einfach eine vorschreife hallo vorschreife und ruft das ein paar mal auf und wir rufen
das einmal auf 3 was war das user s bin time minus v dotnet run gucken wie viel es jetzt
oh was ist kaputt ach nee es ist ja auch nicht dotnet run es ist es ist dotnet run user s
bin time so und er ist jetzt der meinung wir haben minus v wie viel ram brauchen wir wir
brauchen ram was sind es 22 mb irgendwie sowas irgendwie war irgendwas um 22 mb ok und jetzt
rufen wir das ganze mal ein bisschen öfters auf das hat noch nicht gereicht wir brauchen
nicht wirklich bedeuten mehr ram scheint alles scheint alles zu funktionieren aus bis sie
viel gut es war vielleicht jetzt war es vielleicht ein bisschen viel wo ich zu denken so nee also
so viel haben so viel brauchen war so viel brauchen war mit einer million mal aufrufen
und so viel braun ja kein unterschied also da liegt nix da wird nix geleaked kein kein
gelieke fertig folks dankeschön für den sub da liegt nix ok das funktioniert ok wir wissen
schon mal wie man strings übergeben es macht zwar nicht wirklich das wie die funktion heißt
aber soll mir recht sein ok das muss ich wissen wie man strings übergibt weil wenn
ich später beispielsweise eine ein dateifahrt indizieren lassen will über die über die
text search engine in russ dann muss das ja als text übergeben werden das ist das ist
das ist nicht per programming das ist backseat programming so ok nexus nexus structs übergeben
jetzt wirds jetzt wirds langsam kriminell hätte mein opa gesagt ja also keine ahnung
keckel struct wir fallen langsam keine funktionsnamen mehr ein so jetzt wirds schwierig alles void
und casten ok also weißt du was ohne scheiß ich glaube die bessere variante ist wirklich
jason übergeben und pasen also wir haben ein struct in russ alles klar wir haben einen
jason commando für was das denn ja das war gestern ist klar hast du den string auch
zurückgegeben ne wenn ich den zurückgebe haben wir bestimmt in memory league also ich
müsste jetzt den string irgendwie zusammen packen und dann ok dann machen wir erstmal
gucken wir uns erstmal das noch mal mit dem memory league und dem string an also also
hier das ist das ist s1 das ist in russ irgendwie auch nice man kann das darf das überschreiben
oder so so und wie wie wie hänge ich das jetzt überhaupt zusammen s1 plus s2 wird
wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren oder wie doch einfach so unknown ne das geht nicht
haha so einfach ist es nicht so einfach ist es nicht moment das ist ein anderer fehler
cannot add ja gut ok da wirds das das wird jetzt schwierig wie moment moment das stimmt
ja auch überhaupt nicht was ich da mache ich muss bestimmt noch so was wie unwrap
oder sowas dahinter machen to string to string ist immer gut das sowas wie concat jetzt wird
sie aber experimentell langsam ne ne ne ne einfach format makro verwenden ich glaube
ich muss das vorher erst in den rust string umwandeln bevor das funktioniert jaja da sagt
es geht so nicht ok aber wenn ich so mache gehts oder was moment warum geht es denn so
jetzt return jetzt machen unsere etfs meine stonks sind richtig gut wieder massive stonks
ich sag euch das mal kurz moment ich muss mal kurz den broker hier aufmachen meine stonks
sind schon 694 euro die woche 1800 euro in 5 monat gehen richtig rauf die stonks allein
heute 196 euro big big stonks so wie return ich das jetzt überhaupt gescheit ich mein
wahrscheinlich muss ich auch wieder sowas returnen weil ansonsten wirds wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren und da ist die frage wie ich das in ein da gibt es auch bestimmt sowas
wie c c char ne string to ne ach du scheiße from pointer to string wie kriege ich das
jetzt wieder in den c string kucke mal ne keine ahnung wie kriege ich es pointer es
pointer klingt doch gut es pointer und dann ist es einfach konst u8 ist mir doch egal
ob es ein konst char ist oder ein konst u8 ist doch eh alles das gleiche geht das jetzt
oh java cubed hat da ein massive 5 header dings reingepostet in chat was ist das für
eine ausgeburt der hölle hier into box string box liegt was was ja sie schabt sind utf 16
strings das ist richtig mal gucken wie man das jetzt das müssen wir dem wahrscheinlich
auf der dot net seite jetzt beibringen ok lassen wir das mal so kompilieren den kram
was passiert jetzt wenn ich das ausführe crash start oder sollte erstmal gar nichts
passieren ne ok return wert ist ein string oh double free detected und tschüss
double free wo wo double freen wir hier irgendwas freet das rast irgendwann
noch mal oder ok ich mache jetzt das ich mache jetzt das was der chat hier vorgeschlagen
hat das da ich habe keine ahnung was ich was ich dir hier ausführe das wird am ende
gefriert stimmt das ist ja nur eine referenz die danach ausge- aha aha ok verstehe so mach
es konst string ans s what the fuck ist das
jetzt zetscher muss ich machen oder acht du große acht du große kacke ne was casting
mutz dr es konst die acht ist invalid sauerei anzeige was ist das hier warum ist das invalid
in go wäre das nicht passiert das ist richtig ich habe absolut ich bewege mich auf territorium
von dem ich absolut keine ahnung habe ja was es mutz dr jetzt chat jetzt was
so oder so muss ich machen moment moment so so so ich vergesse so funktioniert das nicht
so wird das nix so wir das nix ach du scheiße ok mal kurz gucken was diese hilfe seid hier
dazu sagt wie das mit strengs es
ich versuche als string zu getan von von rust nach dotnet ohne dass er gefried wird wenn
dann muss man den string irgendwie auf dem hip das macht das hier ja das macht ja box
liegt soweit ich mir das vorstellen kann ja so
expected konst schafft mutt mutz dr ok dann dann return ich einfach dann return ich einfach
mutz dr ist so auch ok easy wenn er das so will return ich mutz dr easy kompiliert nicht
alter was was will er von mir aus kompiliert poc not ffe safe ja das ist schon mal schlecht
ich hab so keine ahnung was ich mach mach einfach string into raw wenn ich string into
raw mache dann ist aber das problem into raw parts gibts nur dann ist das problem dass
er das fried am ende von der funktion und dann ist es weg so mal gucken was passiert
mal gucken was passiert wenn ich das jetzt wenn ich das jetzt string return ok lesen
wir uns gleich durch ok also mal gucken was passiert wenn ich das jetzt ausführe das
funktioniert leute das funktioniert aber jetzt haben wir memory leaks jetzt haben wir
garantiert memory leaks oder noch mal kurz noch mal kurz checken jetzt jetzt haben wir
bestimmt memory leaks jetzt jetzt haben wir bestimmt memory leaks also wir brauchen wieder
hier 22 mb wir haben keine memory leaks glaube ich aber nett wir haben keine memory leaks
wie geht denn das aus irgendwelche gründen ist das safe was wir hier machen ich hab absolut
keine ahnung warum das safe ist wenn ich ehrlich bin warum ist das safe was wir hier
machen also
dotnet freet das wohl für mich danach krasser scheiß es hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht ich
hätte gedacht wir memory leaken jetzt ein bisschen aber ok wunderbar alles klar so macht
man es wahrscheinlich nicht aber ja was auch immer leute ich lasse es jetzt mal gut sein
damit ich mache wir versuchen das jetzt damit structs was genau sind memory leaks naja wenn
du mehr also wenn du speicher anfragst vom betriebssystem den aber nicht mehr freigibst
dann liegst du memory weil du brauchst immer mehr speicher und immer mehr speicher du gibst
nicht allen speicher frei den du angefordert hast also wenn du nicht allen speicher freigibst
den du anfordert hast dann hast du ein memory leak so jetzt probieren wir das mal mit structs
also wenn man an kommentaren nicht dass irgendjemand denkt so macht man das so macht man das nicht
wofür den ganzen krampf wissen wie es geht ok und jetzt structs übergeben also sample
struct schon mal optimaler name rast function hier hier steht doch noch mal wie das mit
dem string funktioniert length ah ok der gibt der expose noch eine free function wo ich
den danach freeen kann was ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht brauche weil aus irgendwelchen
gründen dort nettingrahmen für mich gefried hat ja das ist die bessere variante hier
warum sollte ich proto buff verwenden für die übergabe wenn ich einfach memory übergeben
also dann machen wir das mal anders also das hier kommt weg so mutt mutt cc ccha so und
jetzt gucken wir mal ob das liegt oder nicht heckle bamm hat kompiliert moment das ist
auch in rust so das ist das gleiche oder also wenn ich return hinschreibe oder das hinten
stehen lasse das ist das gleiche so jetzt probieren wir das noch mal aus wie nicht
free time also wie viel memory brauchen wir 22 jmb ok und jetzt noch mal eine schleife drum herum
dass wir hier nichts liegen oder findet ihr das nicht auch verdächtig dass hier nichts
memory liegt das finde das sehr verdächtig oh guck mal ich habe auch kaum noch freien ram
oh guck mal mein ram ist voll warum ist mein ram so voll was was läuft im hintergrund was mein
ram so voll macht läuft da noch irgendwas also es ist ziemlich sus dass das angeblich nicht
liegt aber anscheinend liegt das wirklich nicht sehr sehr sehr sehr merkwürdig aber ok vielleicht
vielleicht muss ich den return wert irgendwie verwenden guck mal wenn ich sage void also
spätestens jetzt müsste ich den kram doch liegen oder wartet mal oder oder räumt er das hier auf
an der stelle das kommt mir sehr sehr merkwürdig vor dass hier kein memory links liegen das
funktioniert das liegt nicht was braucht eigentlich gerade meinen ganzen ram mal blöde blöde frage
was ist was ist hier eigentlich gerade so so pepo fett was mein ganzen ram frisst ob sie
hat mich vertippt nicht filter was mache ich denn sort bei memory nix frisst mein ram ach
nee passt doch ist auch available ist doch alles gut ne ist doch alles gut das wurde halt mal
angefordert ist mittlerweile wieder freigegeben nee es ist eigentlich alles in ordnung das ist
alles in ordnung ich würde sagen da memory liegt nix ich bin mir zwar nicht so ganz sicher warum
aber es memory liegt aus irgendwelchen gründen nix es ergibt wenig sinn oder vielleicht ist
aber dort net auch so schlau und räumt es danach automatisch wieder auf ich habe keine ahnung also
ich habe schon die ein oder anderen interop memory links produziert aber aus irgendwelchen gründen
verursacht dass kein memory liegt das ist mir auch sehr sus patrick wirklich wirklich äußerst äußerst
äußerst sus
ne wartet mal wir probieren was anderes vielleicht ist auch die anzeige vielleicht doch die anzeige
nicht wir machen einfach dort net bild wie geht das mal dort net bild need dot net publish
machen configuration release jawoll moment wir wollen richtige wir wollen das richtige ordner
und wir wollen nach dort net net publish ich glaube nämlich dass das gar nicht das richtige
gemisst aktuell bild konsole app so jetzt probieren das nämlich doch mal aus
ja das ist die konsole output ok das schon mal was anderes
jetzt power 113 113 mb
ne wobei das ist jetzt ja ich habe sie im release im release dings gebildet
also ich habe kein leute ich habe ernsthaft keine ahnung warum das nicht nicht memory liegt
auf der einen seite sollte sollte man sich ja freuen ja aber
das memory liegt nicht gut soll mir recht sein das memory liegt nicht alles klar easy
ok ich glaube es auch nicht aber anscheinend
anscheinend juckt ihn das nicht ich ich pflege es nicht aber anscheinend
aus irgendwelchen gründen funktioniert das es ergibt wenig sinn
das müsste deutlich mehr liegen bei so viel durch das das müsste schon ein bisschen mehr
ok keine ahnung wir machen mal weiter das das muss bei gelegenen wie kann man net in
truss definitiv ein memory leak wollen wir die strings einfach länger machen
ob es dann ob es dann irgendwie ob es dann mehr liegt
ja das ist aber auch die konsolen ausgabe
ok da liegt nichts ich weiß nicht warum wie kann ich denn in rust wie kann ich denn in
rust definitiv ein ein memory leak produzieren hat da irgendeiner eine ahnung kann ich einfach
sagen ich will jetzt 50 mb ram anfordern oder sowas
c rust das muss doch gehen wie mache ich das lip c jawoll sowas sowas da will ich haben
ok das machen wir jetzt ich will als memory liegen in rust und nicht dialogue memory liegen
und wie viel ich will mehr haben als was zum alter was ist das wieder für eine sonntags
und wie viel kann ich da jetzt angeben wie viel wie viel beides ich haben will das ist
doch das ist doch nur ein beid jetzt
da bin ich zu ppega für wie funktioniert das jetzt
rust ich will ich will einfach ram haben gibt gibt mir ram
ram please
monkaS warum ist das in rust alles so kompliziert ich will einfach ram und ram liegen und
ah from size
from size
ich bin da echt zu ppega für das ich will ram from
kann ich einfach so memory anfordern size ok size 1024
so und jetzt
doch egal was das da macht
unwrap muss ich bestimmt machen unwrap
dann brauchen wir in rust immer unwrappen dann funktioniert das
unsafe block oh nein
so das sollte jetzt aber memory liegen oder
komm wir machen noch mal mehr hier
1k 10k oder 1mb haben wir jetzt ungefähr
so
so das sollte jetzt aber wirklich memory liegen
das liegt kein memory ich check es nicht sehr sus sehr sehr sus
mega mega sus
hyper hyper sus alter
das muss ich mir das muss ich mir bei gelegener angucken ich hab da immer noch meine meine
zweifel das
was auch immer
so wir machen jetzt weiter mit structs weil string zeug scheint irgendwie besser zu funktionieren
als erwartet und gleichermaßen ich weiß nicht warum es so funktioniert
so das nehmen wir mal jetzt mit structs weiter also hier keckel struct haben wir jetzt als
ok wir wollen keine strings haben in dem fall sondern structs
beste funktionsnamen da weiß man gleich was sache ist ja
also test ups was jetzt was haben jetzt vertippt
irgendwo hab ich miss eingegeben leute wo hab ich wo hab ich miss getippt
ah es ist nicht in der klasse null
klar mal zu
wir übergeben jetzt mal einen struct also sprich
sample sample struct das heißt das brauchen wir jetzt in c-sharp brauchen wir das gleiche
also sprich das da brauchen wir als struct in dot net
das ist ja relativ easy da muss man struct da muss man einmal glaube ich memory layout
oder so was drüber drüber schreiben dass das funktioniert
ich erinnere mich da dunkel welches theme benutzt du für deine ide
das ist das rider das ist das rider standard theme
rider dark ist das und das gleiche habe ich auch hier in
sea line das ist auch rider themes für alles andere
so struct sample struct name ist ja logischerweise egal
so ach nee moment und jetzt muss man sagen i16 und keine ahnung
i1 public mal gucken ob wir das jetzt übergeben kriegen
und so und jetzt haben wir public int 32 i2 wie die dinge heißen ist ja letztendlich
egal so public struct da muss man jetzt irgendwie
wie ging das nochmal man musste ihm irgendwie sagen memory layout oder so was
das ist gar nicht so einfach gewesen wir hatten doch wir hatten doch hier irgendwie so eine
hilfeseite wo das hier structs
struct und wie sieht dies die sharp seite aus
ach struct layout war das was ich gesucht habe genau struct layout weil er muss den
kram ja in einem c-kompatiblen memory layout speichern
dass das am endeffekt auch beide seiten sich verstehen was man da was man da hat
ok so simple struct nee wie habe ich das ding genannt sample nicht simple sample struct
was hat er für schmerzen hat ihn noch vorher auch nicht gestört
du kannst ja das struct reingeben und er rechnet plus eins drauf als return ja das könnte
man könnte man tatsächlich gute idee so jetzt rufen wir jetzt rufen wir den kram erst mal
auf also interop keckel struct new sample struct so das übergeben wir machen wir da
schreiben wir da ein paar werte rein das ist eins und das ist zwei so mal gucken ob das
jetzt schon mal funktioniert und nicht direkt hallo und nicht direkt crash beim aufrufen
vor 20 und 69 ihr habt recht wenn schon wenn schon dann richtig ja so ran er crash schon
mal nicht das schon mal gut warum warum moment warum crash der nicht das ergibt überhaupt
keinen sinn na gut ich ich sag nix sample struct so wie macht man das mit dem sample
jetzt wie übergibt man das jetzt kann ich kann man einfach in rust sagen dass das hier
ist dann quasi ein ein sample struct geht das so und dann sagen wir hier struct eins
field one und da steht dann vor 20 drin stand ganz oben wo das ist return wert returning
simple struct ich will ja quasi callings mit einem simple struct so was macht er jetzt
er bildet er bildet ohne probleme alles klar so struct value doppel punkt dass wir auch
wissen dass das aufgerufen hat so führen wir mal aus und jetzt crash nein wie wie das
geht einfach das ist aber tatsächlich relativ einfach was juckt ihn ein was hat er hier
eiferschmerzen in meiner ide das juckt ihn noch davor auch nicht warum brauche ich jetzt
auf einmal hier irgendwas und davor nett also das ist ok aber weil das keckel struct heißt
ist nicht ok wenn die stru- wenn das struct ein string hat das probiere ich jetzt nicht
aus dann wird es wahrscheinlich komplizierter das hat jetzt einfach funktioniert das glaube
jemand value eins value zwei struct value eins vor 20 struct value 269 das funktioniert
tatsächlich was jetzt natürlich komplizierter wird ist wenn ich jetzt es eins sage keine
ahnung 2 gleich das geht natürlich so einfach nicht das ist immutable kann ich ihm einfach
sagen ich will das mutt und und und mutt haben funktioniert ok und jetzt ist halt die frage
ob da jetzt auf der dotnet seite auch wirklich es crash oder irgendwas er macht nichts mehr
das funktioniert so nicht ich glaube ich glaube da kackt jetzt ab sample struct was ändere
ich denn hier field 2 ok ne das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert nicht also das darf
ich hier anscheinend nicht mutable übergeben jetzt halt nur die frage wie kriege ich das
mutable dass ich das also nicht mutable funktioniert ohne probleme da hat überhaupt keine schmerzen
mit kann man keinen pointer akzeptieren in rust doch eine mutable kopie machen ändern
und return feife chat so in die frage wie also let mutt mein clone oder sowas gleich
struct kann man das so machen man klaut das jetzt ne oder das wird wahrscheinlich so nicht
funktionieren oder doch ich weiß dass es kein clone ist aber ich weiß nicht wie ich es
besser mache ok ok ok das geht ne markt das geht schon mal net kaputt return sample struct
das kompiliert und das funktioniert leute es geht das geht einfach
es ist kein clone es ist irgendeine referenz oder so keine ahnung aber easy das geht es
ist der c memory alignment beste aber aus gründen die sich mir nicht ganz erschließen
scheint es zu funktionieren guck mal hier und was die für einen riesen akt machen hier
wobei im prinzip ist es doch relativ ähnlich zu dem was die
strut ok strut return ist deutlich einfacher als string return wie es aussieht easy
interessant ok hier eine idee in c sharp das sample struct
als variable machen die rein geben in die funktion dann die variable plus das return
print maybe moment was langsamer das war das war das waren zu feife tige zu viel information
für mich in einem satz jetzt also in c sharp das sample struct als variable machen ok
die rein du meinst in pointer rein geben in die funktion ok das ist eine gute idee weil
so direkt bei value und so ist wahrscheinlich relativ easy also du meinst quasi im prinzip
sowas hier wie machen man das jetzt gescheit du meinst quasi sowas hier ja nur mit dem
unterschied ich meine das ist ja das ist ja schon wie mach ich da jetzt ach du scheiße
die mache ich da jetzt ein pointer zu überhaupt das muss das ist auf jeden fall uns safe unsafe
irgendwie in pointer oder so das ref keyword ja aber ich glaube nicht dass das ref keyword
du hast schon aber ich glaube nicht dass das ref keyword unter der haube dafür sorgt dass
es ein c pointer wird oder das ist ja intern aber so in c sharp intern wird das funktionieren
aber ob das in c macht er da wirklich ein pointer draus also quasi sowas hier ja ok
dass das jetzt stimmt ist ist klar weil es auf die falsche speicher adresse zeigt und
wir haben irgendwo 69 rein geschrieben alles klar aber das mit dem übergeben scheint
schon mal funktioniert zu haben ok jetzt müssen wir nur noch über jetzt müssen wir nur gucken
also ich bekomme jetzt kein strack ich bekomme ja eigentlich ein sample strack pointer kriege
ich da rein war das mal kurz weg ich bekomme ja ein sample strack pointer rein das sollte
ja so nicht funktionieren so also muss ich das jetzt erst mal die referenzen also nehmen
wir irgendwie s1 gleich und jetzt pointer so ne das muss bestimmt cannot move ne das
geht bestimmt anders jetzt jetzt kommt rust magic wie dereferenze ich das jetzt in einfach
so uns das ja gut aber ich mein das klammern ist natürlich das eine schau mal ob das so
prinzipiell funktioniert ne expected mutt or konst in raw pointer type also was also
so aha monka es und jetzt und jetzt ist es einfach vor 20 und 69 jetzt funktioniert
es wieder so und und und wenn ich es jetzt ändern will müsste ich dann so machen wobei
das hat ja vorher schon mal nicht funktioniert dass er vorher schon mal abgekackt ne das
funktioniert jetzt ok machst du das ganze einfach so oder hast du ein bestimmtes ziel
ja halbe halbe also ich mache das ja hauptsächlich so mein ziel ist ich will mir demnächst mal
avalonia angucken und ich dachte mir das ist ein cross platform dort net ui framework und
ich dachte mir man könnte quasi eine windows suchleiste machen allerdings nicht wirklich
gut funktionierend und nachdem ich eh schon mal dort net und rust interop ausprobieren
wollte habe ich mir gedacht ich mache den index über meine filesystem files mache ich
mit einer rust library und das frontend mache ich mit c-sharp und avalonia nicht da wie
gesagt es ist nicht geplant dass der irgendwas benutzbares rauskommt einfach nur mal gucken
wie es funktioniert singlordangische für den sub also ich bin erstaunt dass es einfach
so geht dass das überrascht mich jetzt schon ein bisschen wenn ich ehrlich bin so und
jetzt kann ich es doch wahrscheinlich auch einfach ändern jetzt kann ich einfach sagen
hier struct 1 field 2 gleich 421 oh nee is the raw pointer dereferencing achso ja ja
alles klar und jetzt ist die frage ob das in dort net auch so ankommt easy es funktioniert
das klappt einfach ich muss doch nicht mal was return ich übergebe nen pointer von dem
struct das ist ja also eins muss man sagen die haben den interop code in c-sharp deutlich
vereinfacht früher musste man da immer solche dinger machen marshal int pointer und und
geschiss mittlerweile ist das richtig einfach du schreibst nen ref dran und da macht daraus
tatsächlich unter der haube ein raw c pointer auf das struct und er funktioniert auch weil
in rust kann ich ihn einfach als als parameter nehmen dann ausgeben ändern und es klappt
also heute ich muss sagen das ist in dem fall tatsächlich deutlich einfacher gewesen als
ich mir das vorgestellt habe ja 20 jahre rust experience wichtig direkt den lebenslauf
das ist aber das ist wirklich nice das hätte ich hättet ihr das gedacht dass das so easy
ist austrin im struct nee leute nee nee hört mir auf hört mal auf dann würde ich lieber
also bevor ich strings im struct mache würde ich eher zwei parameter mit strings machen
und im struct ja das ist jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert da müsste man jetzt theoretisch
irgendwelche c funktions pointer machen weil von sowas hier ja keine ahnung also davon
hat es keinen plan es kann sogar sein dass es das kaputt macht jetzt also wie ich jetzt
hier nen c funktions pointer mache auf diese function also das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht
ich hab das schon gemacht ich hab das mit ffmpeg callbacks schon gemacht das ist gar
nichts du hast recht das ist gar nicht so schwierig aber aus dem kopf da muss man jetzt glaube
ich wirklich irgendwas machen die function hier get get function pointer
und jetzt kann ich sagen struct keck so so jetzt hab ich jetzt hab ich hier nen pointer
auf die jetzt hab ich nen pointer auf diese diese hier print print hallo cute chat so
jetzt hab ich nen pointer auf diese funktion in der instanz von dem struct alter jetzt
wirds aber kompliziert jetzt ist bloß die frage wie krieg ich das nach rust rein also
in rust kann ichs jetzt nicht einfach so hier übergeben in rust bräuchte ich jetzt quasi
den typ dieser dieser funktion irgendwie ok call me so wie krieg ich da c function pointer
rein rust callback c function oje jetzt wirds jetzt wirds aber nicht void const ne du hast
es jetzt c++ alter moment moment moment moment was machen die hier für abgedrehten shit
was machen die hier für oh kacke extern fn das müsste ich jetzt ja auch hier als parameter
übergeben können ok ok ok extern function so wie sehen dann meine parameter aus meine
parameter ist void void also im prinzip so und so also eigentlich nix kann ich das jetzt
einfach so callen leute da cacke ich aber wenn das so funktioniert wenn das so funktioniert
dann dann ist wirklich triple cacke angesagt so void ich mein das ist jetzt zwar ziemlich
ziemlich beknackt wait a minute doch falsch int pointer kann man wahrscheinlich einfach
machen so call interop und jetzt das da übergeben leute das wird nicht funktionieren das kann
ich funktionieren das funktioniert einfach das hätte ich nicht gedacht easy ich mein
wirklich safe ist rust damit jetzt nicht dass das einfach klappt wir brauchen übrigens
diese funktion gar nicht fällt mir hier auf an der stelle wir können wir können die funktion
theoretisch kann man die auch in diesem diesem struct übergeben ne kann man nicht achso
doch callback ja und jetzt und jetzt hier unten einfach den callback aufrufen und dann kann
ich das alles hier in einem machen ich meine die ups achso das hat ja ihr falsche falsche
falsche parameter so und jetzt gehts einfach ich meine es ist jetzt natürlich ein kleiner
umweg drin man macht quasi die instanz legt man hier an von dem struct dann macht man
den function pointer auf die funktion hier in dieser struct instanz man kann bestimmt
irgendwie das auch so übergeben dass er das direkt hier drauf callen kann aber also kann
man könnte man sowas hier machen ne das geht wahrscheinlich nicht oder ne moment das kann
er so nicht funktionieren da hat er die daten den namen gar nicht das ist ja kein function
ne ne das wird so nicht funktionieren aber mal ganz im ernst das ist schon ausreichend
genug das ist so schon ausreichend genug ich habe keinerlei anwendungszweck dafür ich
wollte einfach ausprobieren ob es funktioniert aber das ist schon das schon nice also es
ist tatsächlich deutlich einfacher als ich mir das so vorgestellt habe ja ich würde
sagen dann können wir ja das nächste mal tatsächlich die die such library verwenden
die ich hier ausprobieren wollte hier example also was ich vor hatte ist folgendes übergibt
man ein string array in einem stahl jetzt aber du wirst in ein paar monaten nicht alles
verstehen weil ich selbst verstehe die sachen nicht nur weil ich das stream heißt es so
lange nicht dass ich wüsste was ich hier mache also chat jetzt mal ernsthaft ich glaube
es gibt ich will ich sagen eine handvoll auf der welt das ist wahnsinnig übertrieben aber
sag mal so du wirst ein paar tausend leute auf der welt vielleicht haben die wirklich
verstehen was da gerade passiert ja gehen erase überhaupt müssten theoretisch funktionieren
ja also nicht dass ich irgendwie durchblicken würde also wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
habe willst du sowas hier machen ja allen ernstes du willst du willst quasi sowas hier
machen public string array gleich wobei wir können es ja wir können es ja anlegen um
solange die fix size haben wir haben nicht fix size das müsste dann das müsste dann
in den pointer werden oder so boah das ist abfahrt leute wir übergeben ok leute wir
machen was anderes bevor wir jetzt einen struct mit einem string array übergeben übergeben
wir mal ein string array ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das gescheit machen soll also brauchen
wir hier noch was neues
ab zu spät eingeschaltet was brauche ich also zwei sachen erstens ja ich will ausprobieren
was so funktioniert und zweitens ich will eine rust ich will eine rust such library verwenden
weil ich in zukunft mal avalon ja ui ausprobieren will für dotnet und ich dachte wir machen
so eine simple windows suchleiste die nicht wirklich gut funktionieren wird wahrscheinlich
also wir machen keine windows suchleiste wir machen ein wir machen ein fenster das hat
eine input text fällt und da kann ich dann dateien suchen die bei mir im heimatverzeichnis
liegen so und dazu habe ich gedacht machen wir mit einer search engine machen wir ein
index über alle dateien die in meinem heimatverzeichnis sind und dann tippe ich in dieses feld ein
blub und dann kriege ich alle dateien die blub enthalten so und dafür verwende ich
eine library in rust nicht weil es sinnvoll ist ich könnte jede x beliebige andere library
verwenden es gibt auch text index libraries für dotnet ich könnte auch sqlite fulltext
suche verwenden oder sowas aber ich dachte mir wir könnten bei der gelegenheit mal interop
mit rust machen und avalon ja ui ausprobieren sodass dann am ende irgendwas rauskommt was
keiner verwendet aber was was gelernt hat bei so also wenn ich das richtig verstehen verstanden
habe chat ihr wollt sowas machen string array array fahrer so ihr wollt ihr wollt sowas
machen ja das ist natürlich ziemlich eklig das geht bestimmt so nicht was hat er für
jetzt muss ok wie man die strings string marshalling als utf acht so also wie kriegen wir ein string
array an rust übergeben da würde ich sagen das ist so ohne weiteres geht das wahrscheinlich
gar nicht aber also was brauche ich überhaupt für ein parameter wie sieht überhaupt ein
string array in rust aus das ist ein vector oder die vector ist ein dynamisches array
moment moment moment das stimmt gar nicht ich will kein array ich will tatsächlich
so eine doch ich will ein array übergeben aber muss ein array nee nee nee ok leute stimmt
nicht was ich übergeben will ist folgendes ich will ein pointer und eine länge übergeben
nur so funktioniert das also ich will quasi ein ein konst c char pointer und eine länge
32 sowas will ich eigentlich haben so das heißt ich kann er auf der netzseite auch nicht
einfach einen string array übergeben das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren ich
probiere das mal aus aber ich glaube nicht dass nee nee so so schlau ist es nicht ich
muss da ich muss hier übergeben ein ein pointer auf quasi den start von dem array und eine
länge so schauen wir mal ob wir das zumindest aufgerufen kriegen auch mal den ganzen krempel
hier weg da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob wir das gebacken kriegen array parameter so start
null und länge probieren wir mal so aus ob das ob das funktioniert also print wir testen
erst mal ob das parameter übergeben funktioniert also länge sollte ja länge sollte ja funktionieren
länge sollte easy sein länge sollte jetzt zehn rauskommen jawoll länge zehn so und
hier sollte jetzt sind das sollte eine null pointer sein im endeffekt weiß gar nicht
was rast damit macht wenn ich ihm wie kriegt man den rusty die speicher adresse raus so
rast get adress from pointer
was ja und das ist mir auch klar
kann use type alias es konz es konstrukte ach so im moment es ist ja auch s1 und ich
zetscher was mache ich ja für einen blödsinn so adress null ok das funktioniert schon
nochmal ich sag ja auch adresse null und länge 10 also die parameterübergabe an die funktion
das scheint schon mal zu funktionieren so und jetzt muss ich nur noch gucken dass ich
die dass ich die richtige adresse übergebe für das array machen wir doch mal legen wir
doch mal nen array an string array einfach ja jetzt heißt er new string array da schreiben
wir jetzt rein null progu und keckel das die strings brauchen wir schon haben wir schon
immer mal gebraucht so und wie kriege ich davon jetzt eine adresse mein einfach so wird
wahrscheinlich net funktionieren genau ich kann auch take a dress of manage type string
array vielleicht vom ne wie kriegt man war das irgendwas mit pinning oder so ne ne an
save uns jetzt an der stelle nicht bringen der wird nämlich meckern dass es nicht nicht
nicht gefixt ist oder so top uns allein wird es nicht bringen ne ne seht ihr ne ne das
funktioniert ich glaube man muss irgendwie sowas machen fixed jaja genau genau genau
genau genau genau sowas ist es woher weißt du dass über null null nichts wichtiges überschreibt
ich benutze 00 gar nicht ich habe nur die adresse übergeben um zu gucken was sache
ist ja aber 00 ist null pointer da überschreibe ich nichts nichts nichts nichts wichtiges das
war einfach nur um zu gucken ob die werte ordentlich rüberkommen ich ich muss tatsächlich
irgendwie sowas von den pointer jaja wtf blob irgendwas irgendwas in der richtung ok c sharp
array true pointer konnte man konnte man nicht einfach es es memory oder sowas sagen irgendwie
so mem und dann irgendwie es pointer ging das nicht pointer span span jetzt konnte man
auch pointer sagen oder es gibt doch es gab doch jetzt neues zeug dafür in in einer
letzten dotnet version oder konnte man nur ein pointer zum span machen und nicht in span
zum pointer job span to pointer ja das geht
so ich weiß ne moment bin ähm ne ne das das ich ich glaube ich habe das am anfang schon
schon halbwegs richtig gemacht irgendwie so
warte für schmerzen ja beid beid ist schon ok eigentlich charm ist eigentlich sein
moment ne ne ne das kann ja so gar nicht funktionieren moment das ergibt ja keinen sinn die strings
in dotnet die sind ja utf 16 die sind ja utf 16 ich muss ein neues array machen mit utf
8 strings dass das funktioniert das kann ja gar nicht klappen sonst ich müsste die
dinge quasi ich müsste ein neues array erzeugen aus bytes die wo dahinter utf 8 boah alter
das ist ja eklig das weiß ich nicht ob man das wirklich machen will oder theoretisch
müsste ich theoretisch bräuchte ein neues array bräuchte quasi sowas hier select string
um encoding utf 8 get bytes sowas hier bräuchte ich jetzt ja genau jetzt habe ich ein byte
array mit utf 8 strings drinnen und das kann man wahrscheinlich boah das ist ja ei ei ei
und jetzt habe ich ein byte jetzt habe ich ein byte array mit byte arrays drinnen ja
logisch weil ich boah das ist ja mega abwache ich weiß nicht ob ich das machen will ja
das wird doch nicht funktionieren ach du scheiße kann man das jetzt
so einfach ist es schon mal nicht ok ja ich habe keine ahnung
ne da da hört jetzt meine meine c-sharp-kenntnisse auf ich denke jetzt gescheit ok c-sharp string
array dll import aha aha string data string was jetzt wirds aber abgedreht
vielleicht auf bytes null
packst du nicht gerade ein array in ein array
ne ich wandel den inhalt um in utf 8 strings
also ich habe jetzt ein byte array das aus byte arrays besteht weil byte also das hier
sind drei byte arrays und davon habe ich den array das ist halt wir aber ok
byte geht das jetzt monkaS pointer sind fix da ist mal unsafe ach so muss ich noch unsafete
vorschreiben oder was ja meinetwegen ok das ist schon mal eine ram adresse die da
drin steht alles klar also und die länge ist allerdings moment das funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert nicht ich weiß ja nicht wie lang die einzelnen strings da drin sind
der müsste daraus null terminate boah ne da hab ich jetzt echt hab ich jetzt wirklich
keinen bau drauf ich weiß ja nicht mal wie lang die einzelnen strings da drin sind ok
das ist nicht so einfach den string array zu übergeben also in den array mit ins oder
so ist relativ easy weil die sind alle gleich groß aber den array mit variablen variablen
langen strings geht so ohne weiteres nicht würde ich sagen weil du brauchst ja zu jedem
string die information wie lange er ist und du brauchst zum array die information wie
lange er ist und das kriegst du nicht so einfach übergeben ne ich glaube das funktioniert
nicht so wie ich mir das gedacht habe wenn die dinger alle gleich lang wären dann wirds
wahrscheinlich funktionieren
also ein zeichen ist immer 8 bit nö bei utf 8 nicht ne ne ne ne ne ne bei utf 8 können
zeichen bis zu 8 bis zu 8 bis zu 4 byte lang sein der trick an utf 8 ist doch dass das
erstmal ascii kompatibel ist für die ersten 256 zeichen und danach das letzte bit quasi
signalisiert ob der nächste äh wie heißt das bei utf 8 code point oder so ein neues
zeichen ist oder ein weiteres byte zu einem bestehenden zeichen das ist ja der witz an
utf 8 aber ich fürchte das kriege ich so gar nicht an der stelle gescheit raus es
müsste halt null null terminated strings sein dann wirds vielleicht funktionieren
boah ne leute das wär zu wir das krieg ich heute abend pfeifer technisch nicht mehr
hin moment man kann das moment der kann das schon alles für mich machen wait a minute
das geht warte mal ich muss das gar nicht selber machen ich kann einfach ich kann einfach
sagen ernsthaft null wie jetzt wait a minute das geht jetzt das funktioniert jetzt muss
ich noch gucken wie ich den krempel in rust zurück konvertiert kriege aber es sind ja
c strings also es müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren so länge gucken wir uns mal in rust an was
da rauskommt was er sagt länge also länge müsste ja dann 3 sein und länge gibt keinen
sinn mal mal länge ist 3 das funktioniert tatsächlich und jetzt ist halt die frage wie
kriege ich wie kriege ich ein c array in rust zurück zu einem vector kann man sowas machen
hier vector c string gibt es gibt es gibt es so die möglichkeit in die from ne ok rust
array from c pass c pass c array to rust function alles klar what standard slice from raw parts
5 hat time leute 5 hat time standard slice from raw parts data s1 länge das da ok u
size meinetwegen so let keck und das ist jetzt was das ist das soll jetzt funktionieren
ernsthaft das soll jetzt einfach klappen da habe ich da habe ich ja meine zweifel ob
das einfach geht nope das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach aber immerhin es hat drei elemente
es hat drei elemente und und ja irgendwelche irgendwelchen random werte aber ok um ein
c char glaube das stimmt überhaupt nicht was ich hier
ne ne so einfach ist es wahrscheinlich dann doch nicht
array pointer was zum
der weiß ja gar nicht der der weiß ja gar nicht dass das c strings sind also müsste
sowas sein ne oder der muss ja checken der muss ja kapieren dass das da drinnen c strings
sind die rad zurück in rust ne es hört mal auf leute ne ich brauch ich ich brauch die
länge eines jeden einzelnen strings da drinnen ich meine es sind null terminierte strings
das heißt von der idee her von der idee her sollte ja eigentlich der erste guck mal was
ne moment s1
boah ne der hört mein rust mein rust kam jetzt auf
es ist ja eigentlich ist es eine adresse auf das start element von einem string array wo
die strings drinnen null terminierte z ich glaube das funktioniert nicht so also automatisch
das muss man irgendwie manuell machen boah ne leute mein hirn mein hirn reicht dafür
grad nicht mehr aus ich bin ich ich bin fertig mit rust für heute es reicht mir ist genug
das muss uns nix mal angucken das braucht man aber glücklicherweise auch nicht so oft
schon spät was haben wir denn ja wir haben 21 uhr
rust ist mega feifett ultra feifett time ist rust ich guck jetzt noch ein bisschen twitch
irgendwas return to cobalt mit cobalt hätten wir wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die erste
zeile richtig hingekriegt ok leute zweieinhalb stunden rust gedürzt reicht mir zwei kopf
platzt brain lag ist aber halbwegs ok ich glaube ich kann mich morgen auf der arbeit
wieder insofern konzentrieren dass ich das hin bekomme gibt es noch irgendwann irgendwelche
sachen die ich übersehen habe oder die ihr wissen wollt leute bevor ich oft gehe ne auf
der arbeit mache ich garantiert kein rust was ich zum abend gegessen habe ok kann ich
dir sagen ich habe toastbrot gegessen käs und schinken gruff das habe ich zum abend
gegessen gibt es ja in einer woche glaube ich in zwei wochen wir hatten einen termin
aber den habe ich abgesagt wegen corona dein vater hat cobalt gelehrt damals da hat er
auch ibm mainframe sachen gemacht weil cobalt ist ja da sehr beliebt so was getrunken hydrated
ein leute nee das ist heute gar nicht angesagt ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen ok leute
ja alles klar wir sehen uns im nächstes stream macht es gut bis denn cu betge